one thing I did really recently that was
that was just Divine and I mean you
could just God it was just dang divine
I mean you could feel the Lord just just
touching you while you were watching it
and it was the rodeo
I went to the rodeo recently I went to
the Franklin Rodeo and it was in
Franklin Tennessee and
um and the rodeo you'd think it's going
to be a p you know
a lot of people spit and dip and
and even women doing it you'll have a
woman she'll have it you know
she'll have a hit of Copenhagen tucked
up you know somebody's they're tough
they'll tuck they'll tuck a hit a Hagen
right up in their labia you know what
I'm saying they don't
you're like damn which where's she
spitting from you know and stuff so it
can be a unique lot out there but
or a unique lot of people that go to
watch Rodeo but it was unbelievably
entertaining
I had just
I've forgotten how good it was you know
I think I'd only been once and um
and I had pink eye so I couldn't even
see that good I remember I think my mom
took us once and um
and yeah so I was you know
I only have you know my I was
I was infected at the time so I couldn't
see good but it was unbelievable I went
to the Franklin Rodeo and
at one point there's this event where
they bring out all of these they bring
children out of the stands and they they
tie like ribbons to
the the tale of
or they put like a ribbon onto the end
of a sheep and they let the sheep run
and all these kids just Chase these
sheep trying to get the ribbon off of
the tail it's just
it was insane and then you have also
bull riding
um
and then you have
there's some calf like roping and stuff
some of that's kind of intense if you
were kind of like very you know pretty
sensitive it can be maybe a little bit
intense but yeah I mean you'll see
they'll be lasso and sometimes they'll
you'll see milk fly out of something you
know you're like damn was that milk
and your dad's like cover your eyes
you're not supposed to be on this
website
um but they had a horse there's one
point where they some this man had
trained a horse
and the horse stands up on his legs
brother and I'd never seen this
and this horse I don't know if he was
like a business or like a business horse
or if he's one of the
you know if he
I don't know how he got his skill set
really
but he stood up on his legs like in the
middle of the arena and then he walked
out of the Arena
on his legs a horse
and I'd never seen it
but it blew my mind anyway if you get a
chance to go see a rodeo
um I totally recommend it I just I'd
forgotten how great it was how
interesting it was
um the different amounts of talent you
get to cheer for people
they got some hardcores out there too I
mean they got some women out they got
some
strong you know men and women
again they got some people that are
real
they got some people that'll [__]
they'll shake your [__] hand
you know
they will shake your hand
so they have some people like that out
there um
but yeah it was amazing I I just want to
recommend the rodeo if you haven't been
going and doing things that are
interesting or you're thinking oh
there's nothing in my area or if you
just haven't been to a rodeo in a long
time I want to recommend the rodeo
hope you enjoyed that video and you can
watch another and you can watch this one
you can watch this one different options
different choices some guy just brings
you one option not this guy two options
watch one this one or this one